il y a des équipes riches et il y a des
équipes pauvres puis il y a 50 pieds de merde
et puis il y a nous
qui sommes un homme d'un dollar,
bienvenue à Oakland
j'ai besoin de plus d'argent nous ne sommes pas à New York
trouver des joueurs avec l'argent que nous avons
j'aime Perez  pas une vilaine petite amie une vilaine petite amie
signifie aucune confiance, vous
dites les mêmes vieilles bêtises comme si
nous recherchions Fabio, nous devons penser
différemment
qui est Fabio,
votre objectif ne devrait pas être d'acheter des joueurs,
votre objectif devrait être d'acheter des victoires et dans l'
ordre  pour acheter des victoires, tu dois acheter des points,
qui es-tu, je suis Peter Brand, mon premier emploi au
baseball,
c'est mon premier emploi
partout où
nous allons faire bouger les choses, pourquoi ne me fais-
tu pas découvrir le tableau, je crois qu'il y a
une équipe de championnat que nous  Je
pourrais me le permettre parce que tout le monde
les sous-estime comme une île de
jouets inadaptés,
nous voulons que tu sois au premier espace, je n'ai
joué qu'au receveur,
ce n'est pas si difficile, Scott, dis-lui, regarde, c'est
incroyablement dur, il ne peut pas lancer, mais
que peut-il faire,
tu veux  parle, nous ne te pointons
plus du doigt, il arrive sur la base, nous sommes des
compteurs de cartes à la cassette de blackjack,
nous allons augmenter les chances du casino,
je me dirige vers moi, envoie-moi un SMS pour jouer en jouant,
attends ce que
je ne regarde pas les jeux.
Billy Bean a essayé de réinventer un
système qui a fonctionné pendant des années.
C'était une belle théorie, mais il ne fonctionnait pas
combien de temps Billy allait durer. Il a fait
ses preuves,
dans leur esprit, il menace le jeu et
menace la façon dont ils le font.  des choses,
hé papa, penses-tu que tu vas perdre ton
travail, qu'est-ce que tu as entendu si bien, je
vais sur Internet, parfois je ne vais pas sur
Internet, je regarde la télévision ou je parle aux gens, tu
ignores ce que les scouts ont fait
pendant 150 ans,
quoi  bon sang, est-ce que je fais ce qui
se passe à Oakland, cela défie
tout ce que nous savons sur le baseball, c'est tout
simplement fou
si nous gagnons avec cette équipe,
nous changerons le jeu,
c'est mieux de travailler,
je plaisante